the end of last week on the 6th of
August Toni jut a famous historian died
if you read his obituaries
it they say that he was one of the most
lively minds in the whole of New York
and they described his books and his
successes as a historian what the
obituaries don't say is that he was a
great fan of periodic videos and also
one of my oldest friends he and I
started University on the same day we
had rooms opposite each other in the
hostel where we lived and he was one of
the first people I met when I went to
university later on I was best man at
his wedding he tied a rotten fish to the
engine of my car when I got married and
then he went off to become a historian
and I went off to become a chemist and
then two years ago just about the time
that we launched the periodic videos
Toni was struck down by terrible illness
an illness that in English is called
motor neurone disease and the United
States states is called
ALS or Lou Gehrig's disease and this is
a disease which causes creeping
paralysis first of your legs and then of
your your arms so that you can't move at
all you can still think as well as ever
you don't feel any pain but you're
trapped in your home but your own body
and many people when doing this when
faced with such an illness would have
just given up Tony started writing more
articles wrote a whole book dictating it
with the aid of a microphone to somebody
who wrote it down for him and he also
watched the periodic videos nearly every
week or more than once a week when we
launched a new video he watched it and
would send comments
to me he was particularly excited when
we went to Turin to make videos about
the chemist primo la vie because some
years before he'd written an article
about primo la vie tonydd liked the
photograph of me standing in primo
Levy's lecture theatre in front of the
periodic table he said that if you
looked at it from the middle distance I
looked a bit like Primo Lavery
with glasses and grayish hair though I
have to say that primo Levy's hair was
rather more well behaved than mine but
that's probably an advantage
Toni was a bit bemused by why chemists
liked explosions and he wrote to me
rather interesting comment on the video
on fluorine which we released recently
he wrote took me a while to understand
its use and value except as a flame
thrower but now I see you throw it a
bone in the form of Samba animal rather
it is content and then it's domesticated
I think that's a really lovely picture
of how to understand chemistry if you're
not a chemist now tony was not somebody
who wanted others to mourn and be sad
that his passing so I think this is
really a good opportunity for me to use
my ciccone iam vodka glass and to pour a
sample of the Mendeley vodka and to
drink a toast to the memory of Tony
and I think there's a lesson in all of
this for us because Tony shows that
however clever you are however much you
know there's always new things for you
to learn and more useful things that you
can get out of life we will miss him
very much
you